what up guys welcome to the just
probably things youtube channel today
i'm going to talk about a decision that
i made today
um so i decided to hire a virtual
personal trainer so
um i don't know if you guys know this
but i'm not sure how much i'm going to
travel and like what i'm doing the next
couple months so
i never wanted to buy like a personal
trainer
um that was in one place because i just
i didn't feel like i don't feel like i
can commit
to being in the same place the next
couple of months because i don't know
what's going on i don't know when i'm
gonna travel for collabs whatever
but this guy actually writes out your
workout plans and on top of that
he writes you out a meal plan so
you can kind of just like go with that
and he holds you accountable
every week i i want to say and i think
it's important to actually spend a good
chunk of
change on a trainer um only because
if you don't spend a lot of money on it
you're not gonna do it because
it's like why do it i mean some people
have more willpower but i
personally when i've spent money on
something i'm 10 times more motivated to
do it because
i'm not trying to waste my money um
but yeah i don't know just wanted to
give you guys that update
um i'm gonna be tracking like my
progress and tracking how i like using a
trainer and whatnot so
stay tuned i'm excited to keep keep on
going with this like self-improvement
journey
love you guys don't forget to subscribe